[Musique]
le club de la presse sur tv 78e merci de
nous rejoindre en ce début du mois de
mai nous sommes avec alexandre marquée
de l'hebdomadaire les nouvelles et du
site 7,8 actus.fr et avec que nouradine
anja journalistes à marmite 88.4 fm
bonjour à vous deux ensemble nous allons
revenir sur l'actualité des yvelines et
nous évoquerons bien et sur ce nouvel
attentat qui a coûté la vie à une
fonctionnaire de police à rambouillet
stéphanie m'enfermer assassiné au sein
de son commissariat
un nouveau drame également pour le
département après ceux de magnanville en
2016 et de conflans sainte honorine en
2020 le président macron a dévoilé son
calendrier du déconfinement et depuis la
vaccination semblent s'accélérer va-t-on
vers un retour à une vie plus normale
plus de 1700 personnes sont décédées
dans les yvelines depuis le début de
l'épidémie qui sont les yvelinoises et
les yvelinois qui ont fait l'actualité
ces derniers jours les personnalités à
la une à découvrir en deuxième partie
d'émission et puis nous verrons
également les prochains sujets qui
seront développés par vos médias locaux
il sera entre autres question de cinéma
et de trottinettes
la france et les yvelines à nouveau
touchée par le terrorisme le 23 avril en
début d'après-midi stéphanie vont fermer
a succombé à une attaque au sein de son
commissariat à rambouillet cette
fonctionnaire de police étaient victimes
du terrorisme comme avant elle se couple
de magnanville en 2016 lui commissaire
et est le fonctionnaire au ministère de
l'intérieur et entre temps c'était cet
enseignant sa meule paty et qui trouvait
la mort à conflans sainte honorine
peut-être une première question pour
pour vous deux pour les journalistes et
que ma compagne aujourd'hui que ça
survienne à rambouillet une telle
situation est ce que ça vous a surpris
alexandre oui oui c'est très surprenant
parce que rambouillet est une sous
préfecture ton tranquille plutôt connu
pour sa bergerie nationale
sa forêt ses chasseurs et son président
du sénat on n'était pas habitué à voir
tel événement là bas nouradine même
mêmes sentiments ou alors est-ce que
cette cette tension et ce climat on
reste toujours dans un plan vigipirate
rouge au niveau national donc ça
concerne tous les territoires
finalement aujourd'hui ça peut survenir
partout
oui tout à fait ça monsieur survenir
partout mais le fric parce que vous vous
souvenez certainement on va prendre
l'exemple de l'attaqué terroriste contre
le père hamel à saint-etienne-du-rouvray
bon ben je pense que saint-etienne du
rouvray souci voilà une petite ville
vilna je ne sais pas exactement mais en
tout cas assez tranquille et c'est vrai
que le plan vigipirate est toujours et
toujours de mise
le danger est toujours présent mais ces
derniers temps et à juste titre c'est
surtout le coc vide qui a posté un petit
peu toute l'attention sur les plateaux
de télévision dans les radios dans la
presse écrite donc c'était difficile de
parler d'autre chose
en tout cas d'intéresser les des
français à d'autres choses et c'est vrai
que ça vient nous rappeler que le danger
est toujours et toujours présent très
présents avant de poursuivre cette
discussion de parler de la réponse des
politiques et de parler également du
territoire des yvelines qui est une
nouvelle fois touché retour sur
l'hommage rendu par la nation astrid
bergère étaient sur place à rambouillet
c'est ici derrière moi que vendredi 30
avril s'est tenue la cérémonie d'hommage
national à stéphanie mon fermer cette
agente administrative de la police a été
assassiné une semaine plus tôt à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici au
commissariat de police de rambouillet où
elle travaillait depuis 1993 l'émotion
était vive ici cet hommage national a
été présidée par le premier ministre
les jean castex en présence d'autres
ministres et secrétaires d'état ainsi
que des élus du territoire sa famille
était également présente sur place une
cérémonie sobre et républicaine ici sur
la place andré thomas jean castex s'est
exprimé il a rendu hommage à stéphanie
mon fermé s'il a qualifié de serviable
et doté d'un caractère horreur inutile
de dire qu'elle était toujours accueilli
à bras ouverts dans ce commissariat dans
lequel elle travaillait depuis le début
de sa carrière en 1993 où chacun la
connaissait et où elle était un peu
comme chez elle elle était d'ailleurs
partout chez elle
à rambouillet après cette prise de
parole stephanie m'enfermer a reçu la
légion d'honneur à titre posthume
une minute de silence a également été
respectée par l'ensemble des personnes
sur place
après la marseillaise la famille à
quitter les lieux accompagné des
politiques sur un titre de bonnie tyler
[Musique]
ja
c'était une très jolie cérémonie qui
était digne qui était simple et qui à
mon avis ressembler
à stéphanie je crois que c'est bien que
la république se soit déplacé chez elle
que la république se soit déplacé comme
ça dans ce territoire rural de l'île de
france
ce petit bout de france rambouillet qui
a été tellement traumatisée par cet
attentat
tellement bouleversée c'est un éclair
dans un ciel bleu autour de cette place
il y avait aussi des habitants la ville
avait installé un écran géant pour
qu'ils puissent assister à la cérémonie
on écoute leurs réactions c'est une
policière qui s'est fait tuer quelqu'un
qui représente la france qui nous dit
nous qui nous défend tous les jours il
me dire que quelqu'un lui a ôté la vie
c'est s'attaquer à la france et c'est
pour ça que je suis ici pour lui rendre
hommage à montrer à ses proches que ba
est méritée en fait cet ogre endommagé
que tous ces gens soient lents et
émouvants un très beau discours très
bien très bien
j'ai mon père qui en fait policiers donc
je voulais être là aussi pour lui et
c'est un comment dire c'est un moment
aussi qui je pense doit tous nous
rassembler et faire en sorte va de ne
pas
tombé face à ça comme on l'a entendu ce
qui est sûr c'est que cet acte
terroriste a marqué les rambolitains
ainsi que l'ensemble de la nation
ils n'oublieront jamais stéphanie
m'enfermer le club de la presse qui se
poursuit est ce que les politiques qui
ont été à la hauteur dans leur réponse
parce qu'on a vu que tout de suite le
discours a embrayé sur les questions
sécuritaires la question de
l'immigration aussi je pense à valérie
pécresse qui est présidente sortante de
la région ile-de-france candidate à sa
propre succession qui qui a amené
justement ce sur ce terrain de
l'immigration il faut maîtriser les flux
d'immigration et l'expulsion des
clandestins at elle dit non a dit bon
écoute et wilfrid c'est vrai que à
chaque fois qu'il ya un drame comme
celui là dans le pays il ya souvent des
déclarations moi qui qui me laisse un
peu perplexe bon il faut pas se voiler
la face non plus à vous les fruits dans
les politiques continuent de faire de la
politique
quelles que soient les moments et ce qui
était plutôt frappant c'est la vitesse
avec laquelle alors que l'attentât
venait à peine d'être comme il y avait à
peine deux heures peut-être 1h30 2h vous
avez vu des sorties qui lie évidemment
cet attentat à l'immigration problèmes
de sécurité plus largement et ensuite à
cibler le gouvernement bon bah ça c'est
de la politique malheureusement
politicienne qui n'arrange peut-être pas
le débat et puis c'est ce qui se passe
souvent à chaque fois qu'il ya un drame
de cette ampleur là on l'a vu avec le
meurtre notamment du policier à un
million c'est également de même sorti à
chaque fois qu'ils reviennent et qui ne
permettent pas d'avoir après des débats
apaisées surtout que bon sur le fond
quand on regarde les derniers attentats
même s'il y en a quelques-uns
effectivement qui ont été commis par des
parts par des uns des personnes
étrangères ou en tout cas en situation
irrégulière la plupart des attentats qui
ont été commis sur le sol français l'ont
été par des parts des français donc
après aller sur ce débat là s'est offert
de la politique politicienne qui
permettra peut-être à certains dans un
climat vraiment délétère de gagner de
grappiller quelques points quand le camp
présidentiel arrivé en 2022
les présidentielles après la
présidentielle en 2022 et il ya des
élections aussi plus locales régionales
départementales la campagne qui débute
et forcément il y aura cette question
sécuritaire qui va qui va s'inviter
alexandre oui moi je trouve ça
s'interroge aussi plus sur l'importance
des filières islamistes et de l'art et
de la rééducation radicalisation
islamiste en france et depuis notamment
dans les yvelines nous en avait parlé on
a été un département qui a déjà été
durement touchée par le terrorisme avec
donc manioc mobile en 2016 deux couples
qui s'étaient fait égorger alors
domicile devant leurs enfants puis après
du coup saluer le pâtis à conflans 2020
et tout ça effectivement ça interroge
même si le tueur était originaire ce que
si du val de marne donc ça me met le
pâtis le tueur était menée d'evreux
quartier de la madeleine
c'est vrai que ça fait se poser des
questions c'est par le passé il ya il ya
eu trappe qui a été un foyer oscille
entre 2014 et 2016 qui a été la ville
française de son parti que plus de
jeunes vers vers vers l'irak et la syrie
et constituant la marche pas un record
européen dans la lbeq
on sait qu'il ya eu aussi des mots ce
qu'est itunes ou à sartrouville ont été
fermés pour cause d' incitation à la
haine et apologie du terrorisme
donc c'est vrai que ça s'interroge sur
la place du radicalisme dans les
yvelines notamment mais ce que la
réponse du coup est à la hauteur est ce
que aujourd'hui son camp les services de
renseignements qui sont dépassées c'est
la situation qui fait qu' il est
difficile d'intervenir ou justement
malheureusement comme designer a dit non
glisse tout de suite sur un débat qui
n'est pas du tout apaisé donc forcément
trouver des solutions dans ce contexte
c'est compliqué comment vous le
ressentez peut-être vaut-il nouradine
qui est basée à trappes avec marmite oui
moi quand je parle du du du climat à
wilfrid c'est pour dire que quand on est
en face d'un problème qui est mondiale
or il n'y a pas qu'en france qui a eu
des attentats il ya des attentes à un
petit peu partout que ce soit aux états
unis en afrique enfin aux états unis ça
fait un petit moment qu'il n'a pas eu en
tout cas aux états aux états unis en
afrique y en a un petit peu
partout il n'y a pas d'endroit qui est
vraiment épargné je pense qu'il faut il
faut se poser et réfléchir et essayer de
comprendre les causes de du mal le
problème avec les petites phrases
politiciennes avec les récupérations
sais que c'est difficile après d'essayer
de faire des débats apaisé d'essayer de
régler des problèmes
regardez par exemple ce que disait
alexandre par rapport à trappes trappe
c'est pas un problème de maintenance
trappe depuis les années 90 déjà bon on
va pas refaire toute l'histoire mais
vous savez avec la france qui intervient
aux côtés de l'algérie
l'armée algérienne qui était voilà en
guerre contre les fondamentalistes
notamment du gia du groupe islamique
armé et puis du du front islamique du
salut voila il ya une déroute du coût de
ces deux parties dont une partie va
venir en france et la question c'est que
je me suis toujours posé mais c'est
comment ces personnes ont pu se
retrouver à trappes dans d'autres villes
des yvelines où un petit peu partout en
france et ensuite pouvoir faire leur
travail de sape pour recruter après des
jeunes est arrivé à ce qu'on a vu en
2014 2000 2016 et puis le lien avec la
situation internationale est aussi
intéressante
les premiers attentats en france si vous
vous souvenez khaled kelkal c'est lié à
une situation internationale
c'est pas juste des gens qui sont venus
comme ça se dire bon ben nous on n'aime
pas la france
alors on va venir faire un attentat non
il ya vraiment aussi une situation
géopolitique internationale qui fait que
le pays donc que fait qui fait que notre
pays aussi ait visé spécifiquement
qu'après on pourrait revenir aussi sur
des lois des lois notamment contre le
voile contre le voile intégral qui sont
utilisés après dance est un mouvement là
ça a été le cas d'al qaeda ça a été le
cas aussi surtout de neige récemment et
qui font que la france devient aussi une
cible particulière après c'est bien ce
serait bien aussi d'analyser
effectivement comme disait alexandre le
cas des yvelines qui rassemble d'une
partie aussi importante de ces départs
même si c'est pas le trap est pas la
ville où il y avait plus de départ c'est
plus de départ par rapport à la
population
en france je crois que le contingent le
plus important c'est à nice ou une autre
ville vous corrigerez si je dis je dis
une bêtise trappe c'est le plus grand
nombre de départs par rapport au nombre
d'habitants
voilà le colisée la parole alexandre
vous disiez non non je disais je crois
que de mémoire dans le livre de
raphaëlle bacqué d'ariane chemin sur le
sujet disait que soient ses 67 des parts
avaient été répertoriés entre 2014 et
depuis la ville de trappes effectivement
pour rester sur le département des
yvelines est peut-être avancer aussi un
petit peu sur ceux sur ce sujet alors
c'est on quitte un peu la question du
terrorisme en forcément mais cette
question de sécurité de climat de
violence de climat de tension dans les
yvelines
aujourd'hui c'est une situation qui est
réel en dehors de ces attaques
terroristes il ya des violences répétées
contre les forces de l'ordre dans le
département depuis plusieurs semaines
ils sont la cible de tirs de mortiers
les patrouilles sont attaqués presque
chaque nuit un essai dans tout le
département ça va de guyancourt à
carrières-sur-seine
là aujourd'hui ce climat de tension sur
le terrain là aussi on le ressent
alexandre je sais que très souvent vous
traiter ce genre de sujets aussi pour
7,8 actu les jours passent et se
ressemblent malheureusement pour les
policiers des yvelines et il ya des
violences urbaines à tous les soirs et
ce qui est inquiétant oui ce que vous
disiez wilfrid c'est que en fait toutes
les villes sont touchées ce que me
disait le responsable de lg paix unité
police responsable départemental me
disais que en plus des piles
traditionnelles dans lequel il y avait
des soucis comme trappe
les mureaux où s'est retrouvé d'autres
villes d'autres quartiers beaucoup plus
tranquille sont aussi touchés par ces
violences urbaines type la
celle-saint-cloud montigny carrières
sous poissy carrière sous cents sur
scène et du coup ça c'est très
surprenant pas je crois qu'ils ont
répertorié entre la mi avril et début
mai sans faits de violences urbaines
dont 66% pour des attaques sur des
policiers nationaux ou municipaux aux
roses heureusement il n'ya pas eu de
blessé grave mais ça on n'est pas à
l'abri et ce qui est vraiment frappant
aussi c'est que c'est souvent des jeunes
très jeunes même une douzaine d'années
qui s'en prennent aux forces de l'ordre
et ça montre vraiment une défiance à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre qui paraît
de plus en plus forte
justement sur ce sujet je vous propose
d'écouter julien le cam c'est l'un des
responsables d'un syndicat de police
syndicat de police alliance il a réagi
récemment sur notre antenne suite à l
annonce par le ministère de l'intérieur
de l'envoi de 128 policiers dans le
département des yvelines
ces 128 policiers vont venir s'ajouter
aux effectifs actuels où ils vont tout
simplement venir remplacer les futurs
départs j'ai regardé le en détail les
chiffres annoncés on parle de onze
renfort par exemple au commissariat de
versailles
sauf que dans le même temps ce
commissariat tous les ans perd une
vingtaine d'effectifs pour al par le
biais des mutations ou par le biais des
départs en retraite
donc pour nous
le pape est ce un véritable renfort
voyez par exemple sur l'agglomération
des encours on annonce une vingtaine de
renforts c'est ce que va perdre
l'agglomération par le biais des
mutations puisque la province va
également énormément recruté et gérant
venir essentiellement d'ile-de-france de
policiers aux franciliens qui comme tout
le monde par le biais d'une mutation et
leurs demandes vont être satisfait par
les mutations donc si on nous annonce 21
renforts arrivent en courant avec dans
le même temps on vous en perdez autant
un biais des mutations
il faut que ces 21 fonctionnaires
viennent en rajout du remplacement de
des futurs départs et on peut voir au vu
des derniers événements auprès violent
que que villes d'agglomération
d'elancourt qu elle aussi complètement
insuffisant on parle de moyens
supplémentaires pour la police
au-delà de ça est ce que c'est vraiment
la réponse il ya deux questions il ya
aussi la question de des sanctions
derrière elle à ses ministères de la
justice plus on parle de deux jeunes
très jeunes nouradine je vous voyais
tout à l'heure d'accord avec ce que
disait alexandre ces sondes et des très
jeunes aujourd'hui qui commettent sur la
plupart de ces exactions
en tout cas le souvent la réponse
derrière et est compliquée même si à
plus de forces de l'ordre ça va pas tout
résoudre
c'est sûr que le nombre ne fera pas la
faire que la question qu'il faut se
demander mais c'est pourquoi des jeunes
de 12 13 ans le soir déjà parfois très
tard
vont-ils aller voilà se procurer des des
feux d'artifice et mortiers pour tirer
ensuite sur sur la police moi c'est ça
que je me pose comme question
alors je suis désolé j'ai pas la réponse
ils seront en tout cas la réponse j'ai
mon interprétation mais pas forcément la
réponse je pense que le lien entre la
police et ces jeunes quand on parle des
plus jeunes ils n'ont pas forcément une
haine de la police parce que je suis
même pas sûr que ces 12 13 ans ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'est la police en moi je
pensais plutôt quand on m'avait posé la
question par rapport à ces jeunes mais
vraiment très jeunes qui faisaient ça je
m'étais dit mais par rapport au
confinement par rapport à la pandémie
par rapport à ces jeunes qui sont
fermées la journée
est-ce qu'ils prennent pas ça aussi
comme un jeu le fait de prendre des feux
d'artifice et puis d'aller tirer dans un
commissariat
mais j'ai dit alors vous me direz
wilfried ça paraît très bête de réduire
sa je me suis vraiment posé la question
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qui qu'est
ce qui passe par la tête que sinon ça
voudrait dire que ces jeunes de 12 ans
13 ans ont déjà conscience qu'ils ont un
ennemi que cet ennemi et la police qui
vont s'organiser qui vont à la hache tdd
des feux d'artifice pour ensuite viser
le commissariat voilà ça demande quand
même une organisation des réflexions
pour avoir un ennemi et puis les cibles
et moi je pense pas qu'il soit ce niveau
de réflexion
moi je pense que c'est vraiment quelque
chose pour pour certains de très stupide
de très bête et que voilà c'est pas
forcément liée au trafic de drogue de
drogue comme ont pu le dire certains
politiques parce que le trafic de drogue
par par définition ce qu'il a envie
c'est de vendre sa drogue
c'est par ce n'est pas d'avoir des
policiers qui traînent autour de lui et
qui est qu'ils vont déployer des des
centaines de policiers pour justement
entre guillemets comme on dit a cassé
son business non c'est pas son but son
but lui c'est que ce soit calmes et que
en tout cas il ya une certaine sérénité
pour qu'ils puissent sérénité entre
guillemets pour qu'ils puissent
continuer leurs trafics
donc c'est vrai que c'est un problème
qui est très difficile et qui va devenir
je pense on parlait politique tout à
l'heure un des enjeux majeurs de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 vous parliez
tout à l'heure où les frileux
départementale et de la région pour les
départements tels ce n'est peut-être pas
un enjeu majeur pour les régionales on
voit déjà que c'est un sujet voilà qui a
été traité qui est beaucoup utilisé
repris notamment à droite et à l'extrême
droite
mais pour les présidentielles c'est un
sujet qui va falloir vraiment commencé à
traiter et au delà du nombre de
policiers
au delà de la réponse pénale c'est
comprendre pourquoi ces jeunes comment
on en est arrivé là en fait pourquoi ces
jeunes très jeunes qu'est ce qui fonde
or déjà cette heure ci et comment ils on
en arrive aussi à s'attaquer aux forces
de l'ordre et aux pompiers oui c'est
corps munis fendre d'une manière
générale c'est fini puisque nous quand
on était plus jeunes jeux
j'ai failli dire je comprends pour la
police mais il faut pas connaître mais
je compends parce que la police peut
être prise voilà comme comme quelque
chose de 2,2 répressif voilà c'est le
qui arrête ses 1,2 à 38,42 des prix pour
les pompiers j'ai jamais compris
j'ai jamais compris la logique de dire
que on va s'attaquer à des pompiers mais
bon ça on n'est pas un temps je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs raisons à ça s'il y
en a pas juste une identification pense
qu'on en a plusieurs
et effectivement ce que disait
nouriddine je pense car il ya un
mimétisme sûr à travers les réseaux
sociaux les jeunes qui ce film
les jeunes de différents quartiers qui
se filment et il faut une compétition
entre quartiers regarder ce que nous on
a fait regarder ce que nous on a fait il
ya ça je pense qu'il ya aussi l'effet du
coc vide
c'est un effet collatéral ducobu aussi
et du couvre-feu je pense que les jeunes
ils en ont marre ils ont comme beaucoup
en ont marre de ne pas pouvoir faire ce
qu'ils veulent au pouvoir traîner
jusqu'à la corde
et voilà donc je pense qu'à ça et puis
les policiers me disais aussi quand même
en raison du manque d'effectifs de
policiers on se rend compte il se rendit
compte que les délinquants en fait
c'était approprié leur territoire leur
quartier et pour les policiers c'est
devenu un peu un gang les balles qui
arrive chez eux en fait donc voilà il ya
tout un ensemble je pense de raisons qui
font qu'on en arrive à cette situation
est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui forcément
ce sujet s'invite dans les débats et ce
sera effectivement nordine le disait
l'un des sujets si ce n'est le sujet de
l'élection présidentielle à venir et on
voit déjà les politiques qui de droite
comme de gauche et un tâte le terrain un
petit peu et se positionne entre
quelques fois que des positions même
très différentes au sein du même parti
sur cette question là on va poursuivre
ce club de la presse avec un tout autre
sujet à présent
dans le reste de l'actualité le
déconfinement des buts il se fait par
étapes après la fin de la limite de
déplacement à des 10 km les lieux
culturels vont progressivement ouvrir
les commerces les terrasses des
restaurants également tout cela avec une
jauge qui sera augmentée une heure de
couvre-feu qui sera repoussé aussi pour
ceux qui me suivent sur tv 60,18 le
calendrier s'affiche d'ailleurs plus en
détail est ce que ce n'est pas trop tôt
finalement alors que les services de
réanimation sont toujours dans les
yvelines en ile-de-france débordé et il
ya presque une contradiction on avait
dit taux d'incidence il faut le
surveiller on attend que ce soit
désengorger mais pour autant on prévoit
quand même deux des confiné alexandre
d'autant qu'il ya le baril un indien qui
est apparue et c'est pas trop ce que ça
va donner dans les semaines ou les mois
à venir mais je pense que je pense quand
même qu'il fallait dès qu'on finirait
comme comme on disait sur le sujet
précédent
je crois que les gens ils ont elles ne
peuvent plus il va le trouver un
semblant de vie normale même si on va en
discuter s'est pas c'est pas encore tout
à fait ça mais je pense que oui il
fallait qu'on passe par là surtout
confinés derrière ce sera peut-être un
petit peu compliqué ou alors on a un été
serein et un mois de septembre plus
compliqué nadine oui le gg sous le
sourire quand j'entendais alexandre
parler notamment du parlement indien je
me suis dit on va jamais s'en sortir de
cette pandémie citoyens des régions des
deux pays du monde rit ça est compliqué
et ça va être compliqué mais en fait la
vraie question c'est vous l'avez abordé
à wilfrid c est ce qu on ne confirme pas
trop tôt je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez de ce que le président disait
il ya quelques mois encore pour le 2ème
confinement moi ce que j'avais cru
comprendre c'est que pour que la la
pandémie soit maîtrisé fallait descendre
en dessous des 5000 15 jours et là on en
est encore à autour de 30 mille ans si
je dis pas de bêtises qu'un jour où
peut-être un petit peu moins mais ça
veut dire six fois plus donc c'était
énorme c'est à dire que le virus circule
encore beaucoup que la vaccination
certes s'accélèrent mais n'est pas
encore voilà optimale on est loin de
l'immunité collective
donc c'est un choix politique un choix
politique qui a assumé par le
gouvernement
est ce que c'est un choix qui sera
payant j'aime pas m'exprimer comme ça
parce qu est-ce que c'est un choix
payant
ça veut dire que c'est un pari ce pari
il n'est pas forcément porté tout de
suite la part nous par vous par bach par
mois mais ça va être portée surtout par
les hôpitaux parce qu'ils sont déjà sur
le front depuis mars 2020 qui sont
épuisés
alexandre disais tout à l'heure que les
français en ont marre et sont fatigués
mariana qu'il soit encore plus fatigué
c'est ce qu'ils sont vraiment sur le
fond depuis un an
ben je sais pas on verra ce que ça donne
en tout cas c'est une prise de risque
mais c'est un choix politique avant tout
alexandre devise helvétique
les politiques sont nos choix
économiques également un choix politique
et soit choix économiques aussi
puisqu'on a bien entendu que le quoi
qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui avait ses
limites et qu' on commence à se dire
qu'il va falloir rembourser que si à un
moment et savoir comment vont se
positionner le prolongement ou pas des
aides écoutons d'ailleurs un commerçant
un responsable d'un pub aux
clayes-sous-bois elle a lancé son
établissement alors juste avant le
premier confinement il a tout juste un
an nous avons fait les travaux durant le
mois de mars donc le premier confinement
et nous avons ouvert un 17 septembre
fermé à 28 octobre donc ouvert six
semaines seulement
donc on attend vraiment l'ouverture avec
impatience eu des terrasses même si
voilà le couvre-feu sera jusqu'à 21h on
ne sait pas si les aides vont continuer
le fait d'ouvrir juste la terrasse
pendant trois semaines ou si justement
les aides vont s'arrêter on sera on
pourra ouvrir seulement la terrasse est
pas l'intérieur voilà parce que les
commerçants les terrasses les peuples
vont vont ouvrir mais qu'elle est
derrière certains responsables de
restaurants se disent aussi si c'est
pour ouvrir une terrasse avec six mètres
d'écart entre chacun est sur ma toute
petite terrasse je vais pas forcément
rentrer dans mes frais si en plus
derrière il ya plus dead autant rester
fermée jusqu'au bout et d'attendre le
mois de juillet un sale type
oui s'il faut dire oui c'est que pour
les bars et les restaurants la vraie
ouverture ça sera le 9 juin puisque
effectivement ils sont autorisés à
ouvrir le 19 mai mai mais s'il pleut et
qu'on a une terrasse ça sert à rien si
on n'a pas de terrain c'est pareil
est-ce que ça reste ouvert si le
couvre-feu et à 21h voyons en faisant
dans son calcul
effectivement c'est en compte je crois
que c'est un établissement sur deux qui
va probablement rester fermée jusqu'au 9
juin donc là il risque d'avoir des
dessus parce que on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui réservent pour la
foire en terrasse le 19 mai mais
finalement ils rataient pas tant que ça
de deux bars et de restaurants qui sont
offerts dès la mi mai et puis comme pour
les cinémas où il y aura des jauges
aussi ou alors des parcs d'attractions
sans attraction aussi qu'ils seront au
mois de mai mais les attractions
seulement au mois de juin
voilà pour le petit couac et ces
derniers jours aussi oui elle est
effectivement appris à la question de la
vaccination alors on peut peut-être
faire un focus sur le département des
yvelines avec un centre qui fonctionne
plutôt bien c'est celui de saint quentin
en yvelines en tout cas on peut regarder
ce que font nos confrères du niveau au
niveau national ils sont à peu près tous
venus plusieurs fois au vaccinodromes de
saint quentin en yvelines le nombre de
reportages réalisés là-bas et presque
incalculable ça fonctionne en tout cas
plutôt bien presque cent mille vaccinés
depuis l'ouverture
on peut aussi saluer le travail des gens
à noureddine tout à l'heure vous parliez
tout à l'heure de ce tout tous ces corps
de métiers qui sont mobilisés depuis un
an sur le vaccinodromes aussi c'est le
cas ce sont les services de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui sont mobilisés quasiment
jour et nuit puisque maintenant il ya
des nocturnes aussi qu'ils sont qui sont
proposés pour la vaccination vaccination
qui à partir du 12 mai ça sera donc
ouverte
si il y à des doses disponibles à tout
le monde je posais une question
peut-être plus personnel mais vous
n'êtes pas obligés d'y répondre vous
aller surveiller ses
et c'est ces dates pour essayer ces
doses disponibles de vos côtés
respectifs chacun noureddine oui je vais
surveiller ça ou ils flippent parce que
je pense que ça apporte la vaccination
surtout avec ce qu'on entend vous savez
on est un pays où les avis changent
assez rapidement je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez au début de la pandémie en
tout cas quand on a commencé à parler de
vaccins il ya beaucoup de français qui
étaient contre un peu plus de 50% qu'il
disait qu'il se ferait pas vacciner
finalement quelques mois plus tard voilà
la tendance s'est inversée après les
problèmes avec certains vaccins et
notamment les effets secondaires
donc voilà il ya moi je comprends que
les gens voient là puisse avoir un petit
peu peur de se faire vacciner mais moi
si je peux détection pourrait me faire
vacciner je le ferai surtout que nous en
plus on est beaucoup sur le terrain
c'est un petit peu comme voilà comme
alexandre n'ont pas pas seulement pour
nous pour nous protéger nous mêmes mais
aussi par rapport aux autres voilà on
circule beaucoup on va interviewer des
gens on se retrouve au milieu de deux
personnes donc voilà j'essaierai de le
faire en tout cas dès que je pourrais
trouver une date le plus vite possible
ah lexandre oui moi aussi je suis du
même avis que nouradine même si je
déteste les piqueurs et les prises de
sang phobies et comme toujours vous irez
si vous le souhaitez on pourra envoyer
une caméra et on viendra faire quelques
images pour nous d'ailleurs pour la
prochaine version
c'était difficile pour moi sur quelques
reportages des photos c'est un métier
difficile mais oui mais oui j'ai hâte de
les faire et me faire vacciner pour ben
voilà effectivement pour protéger et
bien et puis essayer de retrouver une
vie normale voilà si jamais j'ai envie
de cet été de 10 prévue dans les mois à
venir en guadeloupe dans ma belle
famille c'est pas possible
par exemple le l'opinion aussi changé
vous le disiez là dessus on va passer à
la seconde partie de cette émission du
club de la presse parlait des
personnalités du mois des sujets bientôt
à la une il ya juste un sujet dans
l'actualité donc nous n'avons pas parlé
et on en parlera plus largement au mois
de juin forcément ce sont les élections
régionales et départementales
juste en quelques mots pour vous est ce
qu'il ya un enjeu au niveau
départemental au niveau des yvelines on
rappelle juste que la majorité sortante
détient 100 % des sièges aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il ya des duels des conflits
particulier vous allez suivre tout en
sachant aussi que
en tant que journaliste on aura aussi un
rôle d' explication parce que ces
élections sont pas forcément très clair
ni très palpitante pour le port tout le
monde noir d'inès qu'à des endroits
particuliers que vous allez suivre
je passe sur le canton de trappes par
exemple on a vu qu'elle ira bel le maire
de trappes était candidat ou
effectivement ou les frappaient
candidats on va revivre encore des
joutes peut-être verbal qu'on avait eu
lors des municipales pour vous dire tout
il ferait un marmiton va pas forcément
couvrir les élections départementales et
régionales quand je découvrir font
vraiment exhaustivement on n'a pas
forcément les moyens de couvrir les
élections a la cote ces des enjeux
vraiment départementaux et régionaux
c'est vrai que nous on n'a pas les
moyens de faire on a fait une exception
avec les élections municipales de
trappes
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément
des événements qu'on couvre en revanche
resté d'expliquer toujours à quoi
servent ces départementale et à quoi
servent les régionales de également donc
je peux pas vous répondre trop en détail
sur sur sur les élections mais c'est
vrai que je pense que c'est un surtout
avait à cause du coût vide encore une
fois sont des élections qui vont être
vraiment très peu suivie et à mon avis
la mobilisation et puis le taux de
participation va encore être très faible
et je sens pas je ne sens pas un intérêt
vraiment fort assez assez assez
élections je pense qu'on me parle on
parle déjà plus des présidentielles que
ces deux élections qui vont venir en
juin les responsables politiques en off
qui n'hésite pas à dire que si on
atteint déjà les 30% de participation ce
sera plus qu'un succès ce sera presque
un exploit alors même qu'ils font
campagne plus ou moins parce que c'est
là les trous sur le terrain c'est ce qui
est quand même triste pour la démocratie
on être réduit à dire que sur une à 30%
c'est bien bon après je comprends ce
qu'ils veulent dire parce
qu'effectivement on est dans un an va
pas voilà on sait connaître dans un dans
une situation exceptionnelle c'est une
pandémie on n'a jamais vécu ça en tout
cas nous donc voilà je comprends mais
quand même ça veut dire que 30%
c'est pas grand chose pas grand chose
pour encore et en plus c'est une moyenne
on imagine que dans certaines villes
certains cantons ce sera encore pire
alexandre sur ces départementale enjeu
particulier un coin à suivre je pense
qu'il y aura pas de grand chamboulement
lors d'élections je pense que la
majorité majorité départementale restera
la même effectivement il y aura
peut-être quelques cantons à suivre par
ci par là
voir si pierre bédier président du
département est réélu dans son canton de
menthe et puis effectivement le canton
de trappes où on pourra avoir une
situation un peu saugrenue c'est à dire
que ali rabo maire de trappes pour être
élu conseiller départemental et dans les
semaines ou les mois à venir être
inéligibles à voir ces élections
municipales à trappes annulée et être
éligible en tant que maire mais pas
entendre conseiller départemental qui
serait quand même ce qui serait quand
même particulier j'en profite pour vous
poser une question du coup ça
m'interroge que vous dites vous voulez
dire que s'il est inéligible à la mairie
trappe qui peut quand même rester
l'immobilité ce n'est pas un principe
général
ouais c'est pour l'élection municipale
je crois pas que pour les marchés je
crois c'est bien pour ça qu'il sait je
crois c'est à dire qu'il pouvait avoir
au camembert ont fait et ça laissera
plus cette décision cette décision du
conseil d'état qui est attendu arrivé
pendant la campagne ce serait encore
pire donc là on va voir comment ça se
passe sur les prochains jours mais
puisque la décision peut tomber presque
du jour au lendemain si la décision est
prise courant du mois de mai ou début
juin
là ce sera avant l'élection
départementale faire campagne dans ce
contexte un peu compliqué et juste pour
compléter alexandre vous parliez de
pierre bédier on regardera effectivement
le le conflit le duel combat qui va
s'opposer là bas je parle véritablement
de conflits parce que le rassemblement
national présente cyril notre série no 2
c'est l'ancien maire de la demande sur
le secteur et on sait que les deux
hommes cyril noté pierre bédier sont
loin de s'apprécier on en parlera plus
en détail dans le prochain club de la
presse on passe aux personnalités du
mois
les yvelinoises les yvelinois qui font
l'actualité ont débouté on débute avec
vous alexandre par pur plaisir climat
anxiogène on en parlait de valeur je
voulais mettre en avant quelque chose
d'un peu positif
une jeune donc s'appelle anaïs elle a 18
ans elle est en terminale stg donc au
lycée jean vilar à plaisir et du cou et
le 31 mars dernier en fait elle a
réalisé quelque chose d'exceptionnel
pendant la pause entre deux cours
elle a sauvé son professeur de
l'étouffement
il était en train de manger un gâteau
est donc ici les toucher et donc à lui a
prodigué la manoeuvre de heimlich je
sais pas si vous voyez ce que c'est un
geste de secourisme qu'elle avait appris
au collège lors d'une formation avec la
croix rouge est en fait son ca sens et
ce sang froid en fait il aurait pu y
aurait pu mourir tout simplement c'est
que c'est ce qu'on s'est rendu compte
après est donc en remerciement de ce
geste héroïque
la mère de plaisir la rue ligne la
médaille de la ville la semaine dernière
en présence de sa famille de ses proches
des responsables de l'établissement et
puis bien sûr en présence de du
professeur qui lui a réitéré donc ça son
éternelle reconnaissance pour ce cas là
vous voyez je voulais je vais mettre ça
en avant
c'est vrai qu'on parle souvent là on
parle des jeunes on parle pas souvent
déjà dans bien des jeunes qui font
quelques bêtises dans les quartiers
voyez je voulais mettre une jeune en
avant justement peut-être la regarder
anaïs l'écouté puisque nous l'avions
rencontrée lors de la remise de
médailles médaillés pour avoir sauvé la
vie de son professeur anaïs dos santos
élève en terminale au lycée jean vilar à
plaisir a reçu vendredi 30 avril jour de
son anniversaire
la médaille de la ville pour son geste
héroïque la semaine dernière sept jeunes
filles à pratiquer la manoeuvre de
heimlich sur son professeur qui était en
train de s'étouffer avec un petit gâteau
quand on pose interclasses d'un moment
j'ai senti une pression sur l'estomac et
en fait c'était risqué derrière moi qui
m'a compris mais l'estomac et du coup
j'ai ri curgies telle houle
gâteaux par terre et pop j'ai retrouvé
ma respiration
c'est un geste tout simple que elle m'a
sauvé la vie que c'est ça qui croient
mais elle a eu la présence d'esprit de
sang-froid et la prend et screen
intervenir c'est vraiment c'est
extraordinaire ce gestes de premiers
secours anaïs dos santos l'a appris au
collège en soit le peso là ça se résume
pas non plus qu est à la manoeuvre de
heimlich quoi c'est ça nous apprend
aussi à voir enfin apprendre les appeler
les pompiers pendant leur donner les
bonnes infos tout ça donc c'est pas là
que d'une seule bnf quoi c'est plein
d'autres choses vont rester
c'est bien de le savoir en fait présente
lors de la cérémonie la mère de plaisir
à saluer le courage de la jeune fille
quand il ya des jeunes
je veux dire qu'ils qui seraient pas
venus même d'ailleurs nous le dire parce
que moi j'avoue que je n'ai appris
presque plus par la presse parce qu'il
ya une modestie derrière eh bien il faut
valoriser sa et montrer qu'on a une très
belle jeunesse il faut il faut vraiment
le faire
oui c'est important le professeur benoît
meurice encore ému et choqué de cet
événement cherche désormais à passer le
certificat de prévention et secours
civiques
à l'image d'un maïs anaïs est donc votre
personnalité du mois alexandre pour les
nouvelles 7,8 actus.fr avant de vous
passer la parole nouradine juste une
autre personnalité que je souhaite
mettre en avant personnalités yvelinoise
du mois qui se prénomme solal
il a à 26 ans le 1er juin il devrait
partir pour faire un tour du monde à
pied départ prévu depuis le parvis de
notre-dame de paris durée du voyage
attention 8 à 10 ans apparemment son
grand-père avait déjà fait ce périple
mais en voilier c'est sa grand mère qui
avait interrompu aventure là craignant
pour sa survie après un accident solal
qui va donc prendre sa revanche pour son
grand père il va parcourir 60 milles à
70 mille kilomètres avec un sac à dos de
18 kilos pour mettre sa tante un réchaud
sa brosse à dents aussi c'est important
et puis quelques quelques vivres vous
verriez faire leur a dit jack ça fait
beaucoup sourire vous voyez faire
soixante dix mille kilomètres à pied
pendant dix ans et surtout je ne vois
pas surtout je ne vois pas mon épouse me
laisser partir de dijon pour faire le
tour du monde bon blague à part
partir pour dix ans non je ne pense pas
vous le tour du pâté de maison c'est
déjà pas mal pour moi
thomas resterai le temps du pâté de
maison avec un sac à dos aussi pour
mettre une tente au cas où ces arabes
allaient votre personnalité du mois à
présent noah dean pour marmite c'est une
des figures de trappes
oui effectivement wilfried bernard hugo
qui est a été maire de trappes de 1966 à
1996 qui est décédé le 19 mars dernier
d'ailleurs j'avais même pas pensé à la
date de son décès c'est vrai que c'est
le 19 mars et lui ça a toujours été un
militant de la paix des sur l'engagement
communiste
et puis et puis dans le mouvement de la
paix notamment à trappes qui était très
actif il est décédé le 19 mars et puis
c'est après que j'ai réfléchi c'est le
effectivement c'est le l'anniversaire
des accords d'evian qui mettait fin aux
combats en algérie entre entre la france
et l algérie
donc voila c'était un personnage
vraiment très important et je voulais
justement raconter une petite anecdote
si vous me permettez à à wilfrid c'est
que il était très intéressé lui en tout
cas lui sont vraiment son dada c'était
la culture et l'éducation
et moi je me souviens que quand j'étais
en cm2 j'étais en cm2 à la trappe
il avait l'habitude en fin d'année de
distribuer des dictionnaires
donc on m'avait annoncé mon passage en
6e et puis ils étaient venus avec des
sacs de dictionnaires qu'il avait
dédicacé et c'est vrai que c'est un
cadeau qui m'avait marqué parce que
c'est un dictionnaire qui m'avaient
accompagné pendant ensuite quelques
années dans ma scolarité voilà donc
c'est quelque chose je pense qu'il
résume bien le maire qu'il était c'est à
dire avec ce côté vraiment culturel on a
les siennes notamment la merise attrape
le foyer laïque dans les années 60 il
avait il avait bien sûr des détracteurs
mais bon voilà c'est la mère qui a
remarqué la ville et puis on a eu la
chance d'avoir son fils donc gilles
hugot qui a témoigné à la marmite et tu
me disais voilà être fiers du parcours
et de l'empreinte également qui a été
laissé par son père je crois que c'est
ce qui va nous dire dans l'extrait que
vous allez diffusé aujourd'hui quand je
vais lire exemple le courrier que je
reçois de jambes tu es l'une est
inconnue raconte ans
mes parents ont représenté au genou rend
compte qu'effectivement ils ont fait
quelque chose d'important pour la vie
quotidienne des gens et tous les gens
parlent effectivement de culture
d'éducation de qualité de rapports avec
les gens de continuité ça c'est un truc
moi qui vous impressionne et ses
terrasses etc en fait tous les gens
qu'il a connus
pierre bontemps il est plein et c'est
encore il est fréquenté encore je veux
dire moi j'ai très très peu de côtes
angliche et encore moins des copines lui
connaissait tout le monde et il
entretenait des rapports se rappelaient
des gens réellement sur ça je suis sa
présentation ont déjà des réalisations
concrètes alors à la fois des réussites
comme l'urbanisation de trappes parce
que c' est pas si catastrophique que ça
et c'est bon les échecs je vais dire des
déviations de la nationale 10 ou les
choses comme ça quoi le les rapports
conflictuels sur la ville où l enfant
peut être apaisée et les communes au
café chaud tour enfin tout ce truc là
il ya plein de réalisation mais il ya
surplus lui rapports humains et le
l'image qu'il a laissée pourront que les
gens gardelli sache que ça c'est
impressionnant
touchée de tous ces témoignages et je
pense que ça s'est encore un peu plus de
réussite quoi
pour gilles rigaud le fils de bernard
hugo donc qui témoignent après la
disparition de son père la ville a rendu
hommage on imagine aussi oui le premier
conseil municipal qui a suivi le décès
de bernard gaud effectivement le maire
de trappes a deer ab et son conseil
municipal ont rendu un hommage à bernard
hugo il ya un hommage qui doit être un
peu plus conséquent avec notamment des
témoignages ça va peut-être se faire
ça dépend de la situation de la pandémie
peut-être à la fin du mois de juin début
juillet on ne sait pas encore la ville
est en train de travailler dessus pour
faire vraiment un hommage au maire annie
rabais qu'ils aient dit justement ce qui
retiendra de ce maire qui qualifie de
mer de terrain on écoute on a été d'un
conseil précieux il a beaucoup oeuvré
pour que l'alliance à gauche il a
souhaité il a plaidé pour ces dernières
années il il faudrait voir la ville de
trappes rester à gauche ancré à gauche
qu'elle ne bascule pas dans un autre
bord politique et il a été jusqu'au
dernier moment d'ailleurs une cheville
ouvrière de l'alliance et de l'unité de
la gauche dans sa ville
moi c'est comme ça qu'elle est connue et
appris à l'apprécier à le connaître
évidemment la politique culturelle c'est
ce qui a marqué les mandats de bernard
gosset ce qu'il a voulu porter et la
singularité qu'il a apporté une ville
comme 30 on pourrait penser dans des
villes populaires qui se fit s'occuper
du logement des aides sociales pour
faire son travail mais non il a apporté
ce qui était pour lui une richesse
précieuse auquel ont droit tous les
français quels qu'ils soient riches ou
pauvres l'accès à la culture lac l'est
aussi à la vie associative en dynamisant
l'initiative des habitants en
accompagnant leurs projets sont le
patrimoine qu'il a laissée le patrimoine
culturel est remarquable d'ailleurs il
est unanimement reconnu et je retiendrai
un autre élément qui le caractérise
c'est certes un homme de terrain très
simplement avec qu'il était aussi à
l'aise en porte à porte sur les marchés
en discutant avec un chômeur un ouvrier
ou un peu on achète entreprises et qu'il
apportait à la même considération à
chacun c'est un homme qui ne hiérarchise
est pas entre ses concitoyens en
fonction de leur statut et c'est ce qui
fait de lui un homme remarquable qui a
laissé un souvenir positif à toul et
rapid témoignages donc du maire de
trappes pour bernard hugo lemaire qui a
été en poste pendant près de 30 ans
alexandre je peux rajouter je n'ai moi
je les moins connus sûrement que
noureddine mais ce qui ressortait
effectivement c'était que même s'il est
élu maire depuis plus de vingt ans il
continue à être très présent à trappes
comme comme le disait alliera b ont
continué à le voir au jean jaurès où il
habitait dans la rue continue à parler à
les gens aller voir les gens à aller au
match de foot au stade c'était encore
très présent et est à lire ab me disait
d'ailleurs que régulièrement il
l'appelait pour lui prodiguer ses
conseils et que les discussions
pouvaient durer pouvait durer des heures
il a beaucoup participé à la campagne
électorale aux côtés de l'arabe et
notamment et effectivement il a beaucoup
milité notamment pour une union de la
gauche
et voilà il était toujours présent même
presque à quatre-vingt dix ans vous
pouviez toujours ne croisez dans la
maison des communistes qui est voilà
alors pas loin de la mairie mercinois
dean merci alexandre pour vos
personnalités du mois on passe à notre
dernière séquence bientôt à la une
les sujets prochainement traités par vos
médias locaux on commence avec marmite
sais vous allez vous penchez nouradine
sur la question de la copie de 19 sous
l'angle des conséquences psychologiques
cette fois ci oui effectivement wilfried
avec une psychologue qui s'appelle
laurent sirois qui intervient annie ps à
l'institut de promotion de la santé de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce sera un long entretien qui sera
diffusé de près d'une heure sur les
conséquences psychologiques donc de
cette crise ils sont nombreux et moi je
vais je vais pas être un pessimisme est
bon la conclusion de de l'entretien pour
laurent sirois c'est de dire que les
conséquences psychologiques vont être la
plus importante après la crise que nous
pendant la crise digérer cette crise qui
s'éternise et puis aussi se remettre à
avoir une vie plus plus ou moins normale
et est ce que ce sera possible juste
précisé que le gouvernement aussi
annoncé mi-avril à la mise en place d'un
forfait de 10 séances prépayées aussi
chez un psychologue pour les enfants
dont la santé psychique est affecté par
cette crise de lakovic 19 alors du côté
des professionnels on se dit que dix
séances qui devrait durer à peu près une
demi heure c'est pas forcément la
meilleure des réponses à apporter en
tout cas ça ne serait pas suffisant
c'est un peu trop formels on se doute
que tout ça va évoluer on verra bien
dans l'est dans les semaines et les mois
à venir
toutes ces conséquences vont devenir
très concrète il y aura forcément des
mesures et des actions qui seront prises
tout autre sujet dont vous allez parler
alexandre dans les colonnes des
nouvelles sur 7,8 actus.fr et c'est
l'arrivée des trottinettes à saint
quentin en yvelines
oui un nouveau mode de transport du coup
à saint quentin en yvelines après les
mavs est autonome et inauguré ya qu'il
ya quelques semaines on pas du lac à
montigny du coup c'est les trottinettes
électriques en libre service qui
débarque à saint quentin en yvelines à
partir de ce vendredi à partir
d'aujourd'hui oui voilà 7 mai donc c'est
la société allemande tiers mobilité qui
est un leader européen en la matière qui
a été choisi pour déployer ses services
en tout il y aura mille véhicules qui
vont être déployés dans 300 stations
alors si vous habitez saint quentin en
yvelines vous avez sûrement déjà
identifié un peu les stations elles sont
facilement identifiables on voit un
rectangle vert du sol avec une petite
trottinette à l'intérieur je sais pas si
vous avez déjà vu
donc au début ça 5000 véhicules dans 300
stations
mais rapidement la flotte pourrait être
augmenté à 3 2500 trottinette au cours
de l'été il en coûtera un prix fixe de 2
1 euros pour débloquer la trottinette
plus après ça sera 15 centimes par
minute des parts minutes d'utilisation
est donc cette expérimentation
elle est menée pour un an pour l'instant
et renouvelables il ya eu déjà eu de ce
genre d'expérience dans les yvelines je
pensais à versailles aussi une
expérience avec we trotz a moins bien
fonctionné puisqu'ils ont dû arrêter
vous voyez déplacez vous déplacez à
trottinette dans saint quentin en
yvelines
ouais je reste assez circonspects mois
sur ces dispositifs
vous avez évoqué oui trotte
effectivement rue frigon je sais pas et
que quand on sait tous les problèmes qui
a eu à paris et notamment avec les
trottinettes électriques bon qui n'était
pas forcément brider et qui aller un peu
plus vite peut-être que celle qu'on va
avoir un je ne sais pas si vous avez
l'info de voile a de la vitesse à
laquelle pourront aller c'est cet anti
net
après il ya les problèmes des
dégradations et du savon vous allez dire
je suis très négatif sur le ce sur ce
qu'est d'anti peu d'optimisme non
résident électriques et des véhicules
qui vont être je crois à 20 km
je crois que ça sera ça au départ la
question effectivement je pense ça va
plutôt fonctionné note dans les
quartiers entre guillemets les quartiers
d'affaires le quartier autour de la gare
il faut que les gens il travaille ça le
problème c'est que pour l'instant on est
du monde en télétravail
peut-être qu'une fois que le télétravail
sera un peu assoupie que les gens
continuent retourneront au travail
peut-être y aura été effectivement
peut-être plus de que de clients
potentiels il faudra voir les tarifs
aussi parce que 15 centimes pour pour la
minute ça peut être peut-être rapidement
assez prohibitifs en tout cas si on la
garde un petit peu donc c'est pour des
trajets plus tôt plus tôt pour parler de
l'expérience wii trotte we trust c'était
c'était 2 euros de l'heure si mes
souvenirs les indications qu'on m'a
donnée sont bonnes donc voila voila si
ça fonctionne ou non sur saint quentin
en yvelines on aura l'occasion de
refaire un point en tout cas peut-être
ferez-vous en trottinette mais le
nouveau cinéma multiplexe de neuf salle
de l'ugc de plaisir va ouvrir ses portes
le 19 mai si le calendrier du
déconfinement ne change pas en tout cas
et sur tv 78
que vous pourrez suivre une émission
spéciale bientôt au cours de laquelle
nous offrirons une visite guidée des
lieux une rencontre également avec
l'architecte petit avant goût dès à
présent avec ce reportage qui nous
emmène dans les cabines de protection
report de projection reportage de
bixente mais rien senti steban sécurité
incendie climatisation plomberie ou
encore gestion technique la projection
ne représentent que 25% du métier
d'opérateur
c'est pourtant ce qui nous intrigue le
plus à savoir quel chemin fait un film
avant d'apparaître sur le grand écran on
se méfie meilleur format sur un disque
dur qu'on à la maison classique ce qu'on
reçoit pavia parabole donc pas satellite
en dématérialisé son rempart fibre
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser le film ne peut pas être
visionnées avant le jour j on peut pas
diffuser directement comme ça on a
besoin d'une autorisation de diffusion
du distributeur pas ce qu'on appelle une
cadets m
en fait c'est une clé de décryptage qui
perdent qui dit aux projecteurs de telle
heure est tel jour à telle heure talent
jour qui peut diffuser le film avant et
après on peut pas même nombre elle il ya
donc il faut qu'on a fait ça après on
peut lancer la science il n'y a pas de
souci reste enfin le dernier travail
celui de la projection
pour cela les cabines du nouveau cinéma
sont équipés de technologies avancées
tout était bien sûr exactement pareil
ici sur ce nouveau cinéma une équipe et
en projecteur laser type phosphore
qu'une nouvelle génération avec un
refroidissement schiller qui permet
d'avoir une image on a vu qu'on n'était
pas assez content du résultat pour le
coup par rapport à la taille d'écran la
distance de projection
on va pouvoir se faire des belles
séances et ces machines devraient
tourner à plein régime avec la pause
forcée du septième art 400 à 500 films
sont en attente de projection un an
après l'ouverture du centre mon grand
plaisir le cinéma et j'essaie donc prêt
pour en savoir plus rendez vous donc
prochainement sur tv soixante dix huit
pour suivre l'émission projet de ville
entièrement consacré à ce sujet ce
cinéma vous l'avez visiter aussi
alexandre dans une de mes collègues qui
étaient allés ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que ce cinéma il est très attendu à
plaisir parce que la ville n'a lui plus
de cinéma le vieux cinéma jacques becker
était fermée de fermer il ya
dizaine d'années et dont il y avait plus
de cinéma les gens devaient aller soit à
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois remet que les petits
soient directement les gens allaient
plutôt à l'ugc skywest à
montigny-le-bretonneux donc c'est très
très attendu à plaisir et alors pour
ceux qui se posent la question est ce
qu'il y aura des concurrences aussi
parce que ce sont deux sujets c'est sûr
montigny-le-bretonneux est sûr plaisir
apparemment les projections de films
seront plutôt version française sur sûr
plaisir et ce sera plutôt en version
originale sur sur saint quentin en
yvelines avala sur montigny le
bretonneux pour être précis le premier
film que vous allez voir vous le savez
déjà nouradine noureddine qui ne doit
plus nous entendre alexandre eh oui je
veux tu entends tu disais voilà l'image
était figée n'irai pas j'essaie de
plaisir
j'irais plutôt au grenier à sel attrape
ou bien au ciné cette barre est donc
mais les deux ne sont pas compatibles
en tout cas quel film attendez vous
ciblez pas de proximité les deux sont
compatibles lequel vous attendez le plus
on savait déjà il ya un film en
particulier que vous attendez ou assez
bonne question
moi y aurait non pas du tout fait steven
spielberg le remake de west side story
peut-être mais je sais pas quand est ce
qu il sort ça doit pas être tout de
suite je crois par les premiers films à
sortir garder des ressorti des films qui
ont quitté l affiche à un petit peu tôt
avec le confinement aussi noyé la
comédie de quentin dupieux mandibules
qui doit sortir la drogue aussi de
thomas vinterberg tout juste auréolée de
l'oscar du meilleur film étranger
voilà pour quelques-uns des films qui
vont sortir le 19 mai si le calendrier
peut se tenir
et donc si la situation peut s'améliorer
l'émission se termine merci non a dit
merci alexandre même dernière participer
à ce numéro du mois de mai c'est la fin
de ce club de la presse on se retrouve
le mois prochain sur tv 78 avec marmite
88,4 les nouvelles 7,8 actus.fr et puis
également radio sensations nous
parlerons notamment des élections
départementales des élections régionales
portez vous bien et à très bientôt
[Musique]